you know III don't want to pretend to
climb into Carole Baskins mind because I
think it's a very dark place it's who
knows what she's what she'll try Geoff
and Lauren Lowe the last time I talked
to you guys it was under very different
circumstances thank you for joining us
very welcome so you know I suppose this
is further proof that the tiger King
saga never stops stopping can you guys
just tell us what your understanding is
of what has happened two years ooh well
you know we we have anticipated this for
almost two years
we as soon as we came into the picture
Carole kind of automatically wrapped us
under the same umbrella is Joe and she
tried to get me and included in his in
his judgment for a million dollars I
think she suspected I could pay it when
Joe never could so she fought long and
hard and wasted a lot of money to get me
named in her lawsuit and it ended up you
know we knew this was happening
we've been prepared for it that's why we
went down to factor bill and wired the
new land and started building a new zoo
and you know it's always been our
intention to leave this place we don't
particularly like it here because of its
geographical location it's not a great
place for a business it was it was
poorly constructed so you know we're
happy we're happy to let her have it
yeah it's interesting for me to hear you
say you're happy I wanted to ask what is
your reaction to this ruling emotional
reactions anyway to do it so right at
home and you know it's the next place is
so much better for the animals Joe built
this place as a as a speed
facility it wasn't built for the for the
long care life of the tiger and he you
know the cages are too small
the cages are kind of barren and the new
place
everything is huge we have trees and
enclosures and it's just gonna be so
much more peaceful for the animals so
yeah that's more so why we're anxious to
get out of here we can't wait to see the
animals take their first steps into
these enclosures that some of these guys
have been locked in in twenty by twenty
cages for ten or fifteen years and you
know he just he just didn't care and our
philosophy is we don't care about the TV
show and care about Carroll Baskin we
care that these animals finally get you
know the likely they deserve and that's
why we're anxious to get down factory
well yeah it's interesting to hear you
guys say you're gonna leave behind this
property that has these skeletons on it
I mean I remember the last time I talked
to you it was kind of the question of
how much more will potentially come
about about things Jo did about
potentially things Carroll did do you
think Carroll is interested in getting
onto the property to literally look
around dig things up search for things
there you know I don't want to pretend
to climb into Carroll bastions mind
because I think it's a very dark place
it's who knows what she's what she'll
try she accuses us of exploiting animals
and you know my suspicion is she'll come
here and she'll try to open up the Jo
exotic Park and she'll exploit this you
know animals and and so they sell tours
she'll turn this into the Graceland of
Oklahoma and and I wish her all the luck
in the world and she can she can have
this 16 acres of haunted memories why do
you think she wants it why has she been
so vigilant and adamant and spent money
to get it why would she spend 2.5
million dollars fighting Jo for five or
six or seven years to obtain a million
dollar judgment nothing that she does
makes any sense and you know that's
money that was donated to his big cat
rescue
take care of her animals so I hope that
you know what comes out of this is that
her donors who have handed her thousands
upon thousands of dollars over the years
recognize now exactly what she's been
doing with the money it's not gone to
her Anna was because if she comes here
she's got a much better facility than
she's gotten down in Tampa and it's it's
sad that she just doesn't seem to care
about the animals as much as she did
about taking Joe down and now closing
this soup so I know you're saying look
just let her have it we're ready for our
new zoo but at the end of the day is
this fair is it fair that carol has
wound up with this property you know
what I don't know that it's fair that
Carol ever got a judgment against Joe
what he did I think he would have he
would have beaten that case and he stuck
with it and not running out of money he
didn't cause Carol any financial loss
and that's that would have been was a
guilty of trademark infringement sure
all right now Carol has to establish a
monetary loss and I don't think she
could have is his stupid little magic
show that was traveling the malls did
not adversely affect her bottom line so
she would have had proven damages to
obtained a judgment like that but when
Joe doesn't show up to defend it you
know what happens you know the maximum
penalty can be it can be assessed
against him so I don't think it's fair
that he had a million dollar judgment
against him but in all fairness if she
did win and she beat him and this was
his asset he transferred it illegally to
keep her from getting it so I understand
the dynamics I understand them the law
and the mechanism that got us here but
you know it's we that's how much we just
don't care about this place that I don't
even have I don't have any concerns that
Carol's coming in here and I really but
we're gonna get frapp informed before
they leave I was gonna ask what what
will the zoo like when she looked like
when she gets it complete hell I mean
because I'm not taking care of it and as
we leave so
the bamboo is about taking this place
over and she has no idea the amount of
work it is to keep this part of and will
well I saw you guys we should find free
volunteers I mean it sounds to me like
you still stand true to how you felt
last time I spoke to you which is that
she is you guys feel she is not someone
in it for the conservation that she's in
all this for the money she's in
absolutely absolutely for the money
she's got more rental homes and then
Donald Trump and I just you know it's
you got to do what you do and do it well
and focus on your cause and therefore
causes to liberate tigers in captivity
when why the hell is she got 30 or 40
tigers in captivity you don't this you
lead by example we don't lead by by
hypocrisy and that's for entire life and
you know what I can't say a lot there's
a lot more coming up for Kara Baskin
that we know of and I think this this
zoo will probably just grow over and
disappear because she's going to have
her hands full real soon
with what let me ask you this well will
we potentially see you guys on Netflix
again you know what they they have been
trying to get us to go on - they've been
labeling it season - we don't trust them
we told them we didn't want to
participate in any further episodes with
them that we were going off and doing
something on our own and you know when
you when you decide to do something else
you also sign away a lot of your
abilities to do things you know outside
of that contract so you know if if they
want us they're gonna have to carve
something out with the content group to
allow it and I just don't see us
trusting I I could show you my phone
they text me every single day begging me
to trust them again apologizing for
doing this wrong and in showing us in
the light they showed and they're so
sorry that you got death threats and
vandalism
you know families and ilysm at the park
so you know it's it's sure we'd like to
finish this story but not on their terms
how does the handoff of the zoo go do
you leave the keys somewhere and Carol
picks them up is there any way that you
would see her in person or have to to
sign things over superglue the keys
inside the doors so she doesn't I'm
thinking right now there's no way you're
picking up the the final tiger and lion
proof before you leave that's gonna
[Laughter]
Harold hey do you think they're I mean I
saw you guys released a statement and I
think it said something like especially
considering you're the ones who helped
to bring to light that Carol's life was
in danger
that you're a little blown away by this
can you tell me a little more about that
feeling well you know what you'd think
that a person would appreciate the fact
that that her her nemesis was taken out
of the game completely
and not blame the people who did it
because you know we we in all reality we
say it's for life
Joe had certain plans to take her out he
knew exactly where he wanted it done it
was on a bicycle trail and he watched
her videos daily where she wore her
Google glasses down this place on the
trail and that's where he planned to hit
her so when I you know Lauren and I came
back and we learned of all these things
and I just I said you know what I I he
works here he lives here I'm not gonna
be involved in this when when it happens
so you know we went to to James
Garretson and we told him you gotta call
Carol and and get hurt we needed to open
a line of communication with Carol and
in the meanwhile telling not to ride
that bicycle back and alone so you know
you you think she would be a little more
appreciative of somebody who saved her
life but that's that shows you what kind
of woman she is she's just anything
anybody who ever helped Joe is is an
enemy to Carol basket well what message
would you have to Carol if any today
with this ruling
you know I Carol we hope this puts an
end to your to your site to your spike
in to your hatred I've got I've got I've
got nothing you know for you I've got
nothing against you you do you do your
thing I'll do mine and in the end we'll
let the public decide who takes better
care of their animals and and who is
more genuine in their concern for the
you know for the care of animals the
simple fact that we let people touch a
baby tiger does not make us evil people
and that's what she wants you all to
believe but we have thousands of people
to show up here every year we disagree
whether they're completely and and the
only way that people are really gonna
care about the survival of a species is
it actually experience what this species
is like and you truly believe that we
don't make a lot of money doing the
company I promise you we don't but we we
get all
a lot of people here and it changes
their lives I mean it truly changes
these lives and most of our people who
come here are our vet students or or in
the animal industry and senator animal
school for some type of animal care and
you know they're truly here to
experience something that they can't
experience anywhere else
[Music]